le départ est difficile ariel kayaba
gars quitte l'hôtel de ville de london
et clôt le chapitre de sa carrière deux
conseillères municipales
le changement c'est quelque chose que je
connais très bien que je pouvais dans ma
vie
réfugié burundaise francophone arrivée
au canada à 11 ans et mère de famille
monoparentale le parcours d'ariel kayaba
gars contraste avec celui de beaucoup de
députés cinq buts l'ancien cancer en
2018 et elle devient la première femme
noire élue au conseil municipal de
london trois ans plus tard les électeurs
de la même ville choisissent de
l'envoyer à ottawa
entre le municipal et le fédéral le pas
sera grand monsieur qui connaissent
ariel kayaba gars ne s'inquiète pas
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de limite pour
elle lance le conseiller jesse a moins
qui a côtoyé ariel callas bagad depuis
ses débuts en politique
pendant que la nouvelle députée rempli
ces dernières boîtes et clôt ses
derniers dossiers à l'hôtel de ville
dans son bureau de circonscription son
équipe s'activent pour faciliter la
transition
locaux son petit encore rempli de
cartons et les ordinateurs ne sont même
pas tous branchés mais les bénévoles
sont enthousiastes comme al hekma zureik
qui explique que beaucoup de ses amis se
sont impliqués dans la campagne d'ariel
savoir une personne jeune en parlement
ça nous donne de la confiance qui qui
nous manquent a surtout politique
à 31 ans harriet et à bagua inspire par
son âge et par ses origines sa victoire
en septembre a aussi interpellé beaucoup
d'immigrants de london
j'ai pleuré quand j'ai appris qu'elle
avait gagné se souvient gamal tabbee dit
qu'ils aient quitté le soudan pour le
canada il y a une vingtaine d'années
pour ariel kayaba gaz cette fierté de la
communauté génère une certaine pression
que ce pack toute la communauté alors je
sais pas tout la qualité des femmes je
sais pas tout la cote de réfugiés mais
quand même je peux amener mon expérience
vécue pourra affecter des politiques la
politicienne se décrit ouvertement
commune libéral de gauche une étiquette
qui n'est pas sans rappeler d'autres
femmes issues de la diversité qui ont
récemment claqué la porte du caucus
libéral comme jodie world snowboard ou
céline et 6 e vannes ariel kayaba gars
libéral de longue date dit ne pas être
inquiète et promet de militer pour plus
d'1 plusieurs au sein de son parti et je
n'ai pas encore rencontré de barrières
de problème je pense qu'on va pouvoir
travailler ensemble pour rectifier pour
changer tout beaucoup de choses
logement services de garde changement
climatique ariel kayaba grève cet acquis
a deux gros dossiers à ottawa tout en
restant proche de sa communauté
et l'a d'ailleurs l'intention de
retourner dans son comté une fois par
semaine pour y faire du porte à porte
avec l'aide de son fils de 12 ans
parce qu'elle émane
un soutien précieux pour la nouvelle
députée bien consciente que la politique
n'est pas toujours un long fleuve
tranquille et qu'il faudra faire face à
bien des intempéries
si haase midi radio canada london